reproduction is done now it's time to
shoot this thing cinematographer is
given cameras lenses and filters but his
most important tool is his eye because
he's not just thinking about the
technical aspects of filmmaking
he's thinking about character and mood
and story the cinematographers don't
just create shots they make movies
please welcome Natalie Portman and Ben
Stiller
cinematographers are the unsung heroes
of movies they live and breathe shadow
and light their work is the bedrock of
every production I'm sorry
this is ridiculous you're chewing gum at
the Oscars okay take it off go ahead
you're doing fine most people don't
realize the creative lengths
cinematographers go to to capture the
perfect shop the tools they use range
from enormous IMAX cameras to the
smallest state-of-the-art digital
cameras it's your turn oh oh that's
right Natalie I heard the Slumdog
Millionaire was shot entirely on this
cell phone Oh what's going on with you
nothing I just want to retire from being
the funny guy you look like you work at
a Hasidic meth lab what do you really do
what do you want to do I don't know I
may be cinematography oh I hope that
works out for you
Thank You years wizard cinematographers
tackled the intricate task of matching
computer-generated imagery with
live-action footage they lit up a dark
slum and made a brightly lit TV studio
as dark and foreboding as a cave they
put the camera on a rollercoaster ride
through Gotham City as choreographed by
a crazy Joker he's showing a harsh light
on bright
uncomplicated Los Angeles in 1928
illuminating the corrupt forces that
kept the town running and kept a woman
in the dark and they captured a boys
journey to manhood a journey
photographed in places as private as a
bathtub and as public as a courtroom
whose cinematography the nominees are
Claudia Miranda for The Curious Case of
Benjamin Button
Anthony Dodd mantle for Slumdog
Millionaire wally pfister - the Dark
Knight Tom Stern for changeling Chris
min-ji's Roger Deakins for the reader
and the Oscar goes to
Antony Dodd mantle for some dog
millionaire
and I found that very inspiring Nathalie
and Ben if I could use as few words on
the set on a film like Slumdog and get
away with it
I wish I could I wish I could fantastic
and I could thank thousands of people I
can't do it I have to of course thank
the Academy
I'm very honored with this beautiful
thing everybody has worked me on this
film all over this room especially in
this little corner here in the blue
corner and all the people that worked on
all the films I've done for last 20
years they're with me tonight I'll try
and thank you every day from now on
that's my new policy I try and thank
people more on six
I want to thank of course the Academy
for opening this door and there's
something that goes hand-in-hand with
that that's my wife because she keeps
the door open when I come back she
doesn't slam it and I want to thank her
because she's amazing Sarah you're a
lovely lady she's a mother of two boys
all with some Clements who were probably
watching tonight and I get to bed you're
not made to be up on the other side the
ocean I want to thank my mom park of
course my brother John my sister Annie
Danny it starts with you but there are
thousands of people with you and under
you they're all with me tonight I want
to just thank you so much goodbye
stay tuned for a look at the best
comedies of 2008 and more with host Hugh
Jackman when the Oscars continue here on
ABC the 81st annual Academy Awards on
ABC brought to you by MasterCard there
are some things money can't buy for
everything else there's MasterCard